[Music]
this week on
forward this destroys trust and
expertise because when people look at
this like okay someone just said
something seem to seem to have a
reasonable point and that person kind of
lost their career for it I'm not even
sure You' tell me what the truth was
because the all the incentives are on
the side of say the thing that won't get
you canceled so I think that there's a
an impetus on on restoring our K to2
education to actually teach these
principles of free speech and pluralism
and why our inheritance is so profound
and why it's so delicate and why it's
our civic duty to uphold it one of the
best ways to really have a free speech
culture is to work together to solve
specific hard problems not just a
Consciousness raise on the evil uh evils
of the
[Music]
world
it is my distinct pleasure to Welcome to
the podcast back in Ricky's case the
co-authors of the brand new book The
cancelling of the American mind New York
Post columnist and journalist Ricky
schlot and the president of fire which
is the foundation or individual rights
and expression fire Greg lukanov welcome
Ricky and Greg thanks so much a big fan
of yours so glad to be back thank you
yes congratulations on this book uh if
if someone looks closely they will see
that I have a blurb on this book so you
know I like
it the first one on the hard cover we
put it right at the top we were so proud
to have your endorsement because it's a
very very important work um but first
let's introduce or reintroduce people to
who the heck you guys are um so Ricky
you are a a whole 23 years old and yet
you're now the co-author of this major
book and I dare say that in some ways
you were set on this path by an
interaction with canel culture on your
college campus yeah actually I mean I it
goes back even to my high school campus
I was um 15 I guess in the 2016 election
and that was just it just disintegrated
my high school campus and then again in
college when I started to speak out
about my own political beliefs yet again
um definitely lost a lot of friends in
the process but also I would say I have
I have a glimmer of hope from that story
as well which I I can I can save for
later but um tell you a little bit about
how I think that cancel culture can be
kind of circumvented by by courage being
contagious but yes indeed cancel culture
I've I've known it since I was a but a
shrimp in in high school
so yeah I mean that's one thing that
Ricky likes to point out that I think is
an excellent point is that we still have
to deal with people who are trying to
claim cancel culture isn't real or never
even happened which is just increasingly
I mean it's been a ridiculous statement
to make for a long time but uh when you
pull younger people about cancel culture
it's Generation Z that hates it the most
because they grew up in it they they
grew up not really trusting whether or
not you know that confidence they they
told to their friends is going to make
it onto Tik Tok and next thing you know
their their social lives are going to be
ruined so Greg this is your fourth book
uh people who find the title of the book
familiar um might recognize it from your
work with Jonathan height the cuddling
of the American mind which came out a
number of years ago talking about how
where leading our young people to some
very very counterproductive beliefs
which I thought was an excellent book
you guys got a ton of a claim for that
book and this is in many ways the sequel
so how did you and Ricky end up teaming
up on this and collaborating um you know
it's a it's a pretty direct story um you
know Ricky read codling um she was a fan
of the book uh she very also sensibly
when the lockdowns began in 2020 said
this is stupid going to as she says
going to zoom College paying $6,000 a
class for Zoom College seemed seemed
asinine so she dropped out of NYU and
started working for Publications
including reason magazine um including
the New York Post and she was clearly
like just a weirdly good writer for I
want to like I'm tempted to say for her
age I'm like no she's she's a good she's
a great writer for any age so we made
her a fellow at fire as part of the
research team and it didn't take long
for me to realize wow like this is a
very talented young woman um and I and
I'm an
overwriterz 5,000 you know it's like no
no no no like you got got to boil it
down um so I felt like we made like a
really great team and one of the reasons
why I wanted to write Ricky in addition
to the fact that she's just a phenomenal
writer and she's passionate about
freedom of speech and she knows a lot
about uh cancel culture was that so much
of codling of the American mind was
about the harms we're inflicting on Jen
young women um so actually and but it
was written by two gen xers um at me and
hey so having an opportunity to write
with a young woman who can actually test
the environment on on the ground uh
seemed like a great opportunity and then
we got to work together and I thought I
think just think we made a great team
well certainly it shows in the pages I
mean uh you guys certainly made a a
great team um can you give people some
background on fire Greg oh sure um the
foundation for individual rights and
expression uh we turned uh from we used
to be the foundation for individual
rights in education up until Janu uh
June 6th of 2022 um we we decided to
expand um uh from just working on
campuses to filing cases all over the
country we actually just filed one in in
favor of some animal rights activists um
yesterday like uh so we have a you know
thriving litigation practice um and you
know now we deal we have cases all over
the country we still have a special
Focus higher education including our
campus Free Speech rankings which
anybody considering going to school
should definitely look at um because
you'll be surprised at how bad some of
the most illustrious schools in the
country are and how good maybe in some
cases schools you've never heard of
actually do on a 13 Point factorial kind
of examination of whether or not the the
Free Speech climate is good at that
school you Ricky how was your experience
working with Greg he sounds like a real
pain in the butt in terms of uh sending
you super long passages and you're like
Greg no one's going to read all
this no actually we had I I was just
reflecting I had lunch with our book
editor yesterday I met him in person for
the first time and I was just reflecting
on the fact that somehow we went through
this process which must have been like a
year and a half from start to finish and
did not have like a single moment of
interpersonal tension in any meaningful
way the entire way through which is just
incredible looking back um but I think
it was like a perfect pairing because
Greg has all this wisdom and is I mean
this breadth of knowledge and has been
at fire for two decades and basically my
lifetime and could bring all this
knowledge to the table that I would
never have had or been able to pull out
of my brain in any way shape or form and
so it was a really great partnership
because I was able to help distill that
and make it as succinct as possible and
you know coming from a place like the
New York Post where I'm writing 600w op
EDS I'm I'm an efficient writer and I
know how to boil things down and so it
was it was pretty perfect cuz I got to
work with this like wealth of knowledge
and sometimes he would just send me like
a a voice memo I think like so much of
the book was actually written basically
from voice memo to like okay how do I
make this work on a page and it was it
was a really awesome process and I think
like I got to learn so much and and pick
his brain through the the course of
writing this book and I feel like even
um looking at the where I was in the
beginning and in the end it was it was
such an amazing Growing Experience and I
read the book now like I just did the
audio book and I'm like oh oh huh that's
pretty interesting I kind of like forgot
that that was even in there so it's
exciting to see how the final product it
was also great because she's a great
reporter um so when when we were talking
about individual cases you know she
knows how to do a kick-ass interview she
knows how to get good questions out of
people like so like all all of her all
of her skills and then also just the
additional Insight of being growing up
in this I mean it's it's kind of funny
like I I I I call myself like
temperamentally optimistic but in a
world that should make you somewhat
pessimistic at the moment
you know is is kind of the kind kind of
the way I feel about it and generally I
will point out to people that it's
better to be alive today by a million
different standards than it was you know
because my dad was Bor okay my dad was
born in 1926 in Yugoslavia his dad died
when he was six his life was a horror
show and I'm always aware of that but
would I trade growing up as a kid in the
80s and a teenager and young person in
the 90s with Ricky growing up in the age
of social media not a chance so here's
how I think the average American might
think about cancel culture uh hey uh
occasionally people get cancelled but
it's mainly uh social media
related um it's not maybe that big a
deal I find it uh
unlikable uh but it's not something I
should be you know staying awake at
night thinking about now your book has a
number of um awesome contributions in it
uh it's a much more rigorous uh
cataloging we say uh of cancel culture
it breaks it down its impacts on
different institutions Ricky you said
that hey that a lot of this is still on
campuses which I think is where most
people think of it so let's start at
campuses why why are college campuses
such a fertile ground for what we'd
consider cancel culture and for a moment
for people how would you define cancel
culture so I think that campuses are
really fertile ground for cancel culture
because you show up you're young you
want to fit in and often times there's a
very loud liberal minority of students
who are tying people's viewpoints to
their their personal status or who they
are as human beings and and very
indulgent in these ad hominum attacks
and we'll attack people on social media
and when you're a kid that shows up and
you're afraid of putting yourself out
there and you think that like I did I
was hiding books under my bed like
Jordan Peterson and Thomas Soul you
really feel as though you can't put
yourself out there and I learned the the
kind of going off jumping off the cliff
and writing for the New York Post and
saying here are my viewpoints and I
think that free speech is a problem on
campus which was my first major oped all
the people around me felt the same way
or the vast majority I had people coming
out of every crevice of of Roommates of
um deans of of uh like whole departments
and professors that I had who would come
to me quietly and say oh I I completely
agree with you and good on you for
writing about free speech on campus but
just don't tell anyone that we had this
conversation and so I think there's
something about that highly ideological
bubble that really lets this go Ary and
where those really aggressive loud
people who tear people down who use bias
response hotlines because the
Administration has just put this whole
bureaucracy around cancel culture and
basically indulging it it's it's the
tyranny of the minority just goes crazy
in real life and the same way that I
think it does in social media and then
in like the liveaction version on
college campuses essentially so Greg how
would you define cancel culture you it
sounds like you have a a technical
definition yeah I I do have I do it Ben
this is the one of the few times I'll
sound like a lawyer but I want to be
precise about it and it's the uptick
beginning around 2014 and accelerating
in 2017 uh and after of campaigns to get
people fired disinvited deplatformed or
otherwise punished for speech that is or
would be protected by the First
Amendment and the climate of fear and
Conformity that has resulted from this
uptick um because I'm trying to make
clear that we're not talking about
something that's strictly partisan
although the term cancel culture is
often times you know something that
people will accuse the left of being
guilty of and and certainly that's true
to a large degree uh but we also take on
cancel culture from the right because
what we saw after 2014 and it wasn't
subtle was just suddenly people were
rather than just being really
embarrassed on on Twitter or or Facebook
they were losing their jobs um for you
know jokes that that went viral for
example um and on campus uh one of the
reasons why it is just so frustrating
that there are still people you know
trying to claim this doesn't this isn't
even happening the uptick in professors
getting cancelled is unlike anything
we've seen in the modern era of higher
education I mean the law protecting
academic freedom was and and free speech
on campus wasn't really clear until
about 1973 three and there hasn't been a
period like this in that entire time
when this many professors are getting
you know fired tenured professors in
many cases for what they say what they
print uh What uh what they um and having
their research
uh that that getting them in trouble in
actually having withdrawn which is which
is usually considered an extraordinary
measure one of the goals of of the piece
was to of the book was to put it all in
one place and and try to give some
historical comparisons like when you
talk about
uh sometimes people have no it's very
funny watching people don't really know
anything about the history of freedom of
speech claim oh these are you know no
these are tiny numbers the it's not
significant but when you're talking
about over a thousand professors
targeted you know um just in the last
nine and a half years since cancel
culture began with about two-thirds of
those punished with uh with about oneth
of those about almost 200 fired you're
talking about numbers that blow away
even things like the Red Scare where
where the normal estimates about 100%
professors you know were fired and and
at the time everyone knew the Red Scare
was happening like that that a lot of
that research actually comes it was
contemporaneous with it so it's been a I
try not to use this word too often but
it's been a a crisis on campus um and
and yeah we point out when about about a
third of those punishments um come from
usually the off-campus right and we call
those out uh as well but I do want it at
the same time I remember saying this to
somebody on on social media I'm like
well but a third of them come from is
like but you're implying that the the
rest come from the left and it's like
well yeah you you don't think there's a
free speech problem on on the left on
Camp like that that's that's just is
willful blindness at this point yeah and
I might add that on the on the
right-wing cancel culture um kind of
side of things this is something that
like I know I'm going to take a lot of
flak for from some people that might
otherwise um like what I write about and
stuff but I have absolutely no problem
calling out what I see as ill fighting
illiberalism with illiberalism and
fighting might with might in a really
disturbing way because there's like a
wide opening for for people and leaders
to step in and say Free Speech has been
largely abdicated as a a major principle
of the left and here we are going to
actually step in and adopt that rather
than fight that hot mess that's
happening in the radical leftwing with
our own authoritarian hot mess on the
right which is just super disappointing
to me and I I think that there's such a
lack of a a positive restorative road
map to like how how can one one side or
no side or just a group of people in the
center or people who just are actually
classical liberals reclaim those values
and it feels as though that's not a
conversation that happens often enough
and it's like oh we're the champions of
free speech on the right but then here
are all are very authoritarian bills
that actually curb free expression at
the same time it's it gets my blood
boiling imagine running for president
and wanting to share what you
experienced in a way that's entertaining
edifying and maybe even a little bit
scary that's the last election out in
bookstores now a novel about an
independent presidential candidate a
journalist with a massive story and what
the heck could be our next SL last
election check it out at andrewyang.com
[Music]
I agree with you Ricky it's one thing I
hope Ford can assist with is creating
this middle Zone because the the
oppositional forces uh it's awful you
know like and people I know people I
mean you write about them um I know
people who've been attacked by one side
of the other let's say they get attacked
by the left and then they they look at
it and say okay well whoever is against
you I guess I'm now
with that's even though was like wait a
minute I don't really want to be with
those guys that you know and and that's
um really noxious it's very dangerous uh
it's dangerous politically it's
dangerous culturally when you talk about
these 200 professors who got fired there
was a particularly tragic story about a
professor named Mike Adams in your book
and I have to say when I read it I was
like I like I I actually thought wow how
had I not heard of this uh but if you
want to relate uh the Mike Adam story
Greg yeah uh it's a little hard um the
uh so I started at fire in 2001 back
when fire was Tiny and I was the first
legal director at fire um and one of the
first professors I met was a professor
who used to be uh a progressive um
criminology Professor but then he became
an Evangelical Christian and became the
rarest kind of um conservative of on
campus which is a social conservative a
lot of people who call themselves
conservatives on campus are more like
Libertarians um and on 9/11 actually the
day after 911 a student at at UNCW UNCC
Wilmington uh wrote something saying
America had it coming basically like
this was totally our fault um and the
and and he wrote back she she sent an
email to the entire campus and he wrote
back to the entire campus saying it's
like listen um you have every right to
say this uh just as uh
you know bigoted and stupid thought like
is protected he actually was even a
little more careful than that but the
school launched an investigation of Mike
Adams for that um and it was you know it
was an early case and I'd say like on on
the severity scale for my later career
was maybe like a four out of 10 it just
it wasn't that bad but I was new to this
and I was horrified like this is this is
what he said was UN was so clearly
protected by the First Amendment so we
became kind of friends over that case
and since you know you know he he uh and
I introduced him to the works of Lenny
Bruce which I live to regret a little
bit because he would credit me sometimes
when he was on the radio about reading
Lenny Bruce is what what made him decide
to be you know more inyour face like um
and it's funny because I you know I come
from the left side of spectrum he he
comes from the right but he was he was a
a nice person that I got to know but his
style became very kind of like you know
uh calling out the libs kind kind of
stuff but it was also very jokey which
was something like a previous era of
people on the left were kind of like
yeah like the like the guy like the
gadfly like that that's that's a role we
we used to understand having value and
so he had a long career had to defend
him a lot but in 2020 he sent out a
tweet uh objecting the lockdowns um in
North Carolina and being in a state he
was with a bunch of friends in a place
that didn't have lockdowns and he was
having a beer and he um uh and he
tweeted uh Massa whatever the name name
of the governor was um Let My People Go
um um and apparently that was uh so
referring to lockdowns as being like
bondage it was basically a joke um and
immediately in in that absolutely crazy
year of 2020 uh the students went after
him to try to get him fired now since
he'd actually already previously sued
and won um against UNCW they didn't want
to go back into court CU they lost last
time they F fought Mike so they gave him
a severance not even like a insanely
good Severance but but he got a
severance and meanwhile in June of 2020
we're flooded with with professors
asking for Fire's help we were
completely overwhelmed we got as many
cases in June of 2020 as we used to get
in an entire year and I saw that Mike
was one of them and I and I was like you
know what Mike is he's super confident
he'll be fine I'll check on him
basically last and I I regret that now
um because I I didn't get I wasn't able
to check in with them on the phone until
about mid July of 2020 um and he was not
doing well U there were still people
coming to his house there were people
you know uh calling him on the phone he
he filed a police report because like
these people wouldn't let up um and it's
weird how activists can think like they
can sound like bigots themselves because
they were they were calling him saying
that they saw his uh daughter and son um
fting black men at a at at a uh at at
protests and it's like wow that's really
just messed up also he doesn't have a
daughter and son so at least um and Mike
didn't sound like he was doing real well
and there wasn't much I could do to help
him because he had already signed the
sence and he killed himself the next
week um and you know that really hit me
I mean like I I got into CBT because of
my own struggles with depression um and
yeah I I and it was particularly
ghoulish watching some people when they
talked about Mike Adam's death it was
like a you know Buzz feed and all these
other places covered it just you know
offensive Professor kill self you know
and and some of them were even more
ghoulish about it so there was a
professor um who we helped in another
case who was basically like you know
don't worry you know you shouldn't be so
upset about your friend and it's like I
shouldn't be so upset about a human
being killing himself after being
canceled it was um it and and it reveals
one of the things that I one of the
reasons why this book can't be a crowd
pleaser in the same way coddling the
American mind can be uh coddling the
American mind was true to itself
subtitle we believed a lot of the
problems in cuddling the American mind
were uh good intentions but bad ideas
people meaning well and but at the same
time creating Problems by having you
know bad wisdom but in cancel culture
even though people tell themselves that
I'm standing up for the little guy and
that basically I'm doing this for a
larger abstraction of social justice
usually for an idea of abstract people
who might be might might be hurt or
harmed that they give themselves a green
light to be as cruel and ruthless
against people as possible and so this
idea that kind of like there's something
compassionate or there's some kind of
it's It's good versus evil Greg so you
knowly anything is
allowed yeah so yeah that that uh you
know that that one that one uh stays
with me yeah reading it was difficult
and uh and you could tell how painful it
was for you to even recount it uh that
that's one of the things and it could be
that I'm influenced in a particular way
because I know some of the uh folks who
have uh been victims of cancel culture I
don't know them way you know them I mean
it sounds like you you actually you know
are literally standing side by side with
them um but but hundreds of professors I
mean those are human beings with
families and lives and Academia is an
environment where it's not easy just to
pick up and go someplace else you know
like anything that happened to you at
your last campus is going to follow you
to the next campus if you're an
Administration you're like am I really
going to take a risk on this person when
there are probably like 50 people right
behind them uh with similar
qualification levels that will invite no
controversy if I decide to hire them and
but that's also one of the things one of
the subtler points that we make in the
book that's really important even if
you're sure you'll never be canceled in
your life and by the way you shouldn't
be uh sure but even if you think this
will never affect you people really need
to get this is devastating to people's
trust in experts and here and here's why
that when people see situations like
Carol hooven you know who um who was a
professor at Harvard she went on Fox
News and she said in a very
compassionate way about about all issues
relating to trans that you know you
should be compassionate you should use
people's pronouns you should be
understanding but biological sex is real
and we can't um pretend that it's not
and immediately there was a campaign by
a Dei officer and um to get her you know
uh to to get her punished there was
there was a um uh there there was an
attempt to get her get her canceled
students refused to work in her class
which effectively shut down her class
and we don't even count that as a
successful cancellation attempt because
she just was forced out in in her own
words we actually discussed here two
nights ago um by just the the nastiness
of watching friends betray you and not
stand by you so she she she she left uh
Harvard but this destroys trust in
expertise because when people look at
this it's like okay it's someone just
said something seemed to seemed to have
a reasonable point and that person kind
of lost their career for it how can I
trust experts to be objective on this
stuff if they know that the the that the
pressure is all on you know say the on
the hot button issues you know agree
with consensus say the popular thing say
the thing that actually we want you to
say right now and when people are
watching this and the thing is the
expert could actually be right but you
you shouldn't blame the public when when
uh when they're looking at this going
okay I know know that you I'm not even
sure you tell me what the truth was
because the all the incentives are on
the side of say the thing that won't get
you
canceled this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies you use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
that's
expressvpn.com yangang and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
gang yeah I I I totally agree that it's
eroding trust uh and that the
stitutional incentives of Administrators
are just very very perverse uh where if
you can imagine the administrator saying
hey I'm going to defend this person that
everyone's attacking uh then you also
are guilty of having this offensive idea
you must also be anti-trans or antiblack
or whatever the accusation uh that the
person you're defending is guilty of uh
and so you look at it and say well shoot
like what what's in in my interest uh I
think University are ripe for this
because uh of like a a a real lack of uh
incentive for you to try and do the
right thing it's like everyone it's what
Ricky just said it's like look I can
sympathize with this and agree with you
but please don't record that we had this
conversation
because and and by the way I I come from
an academic family I'm actually the
academic run of the litter in uh in my
family my uh grandfather was a professor
my uncle was a professor my father
became a professor my brother is a
professor and so I'm a crushing
disappointment to my family and that I
don't have a PhD and I'm not a professor
but there but there's like a like I have
a ton of academics in my circle and they
they tell me similar things by the way
they say hey um I saw someone lose their
career so now I am going to steer away
from that as much as possible and if you
know how much work academics put
into their careers it is nuts I mean I I
uh I consider myself a hardworking
fellow and I see what uh what what
academics do and it it's a whole another
level of just I in like painstaking
labor over a period of years and years
to get into this perch and then
administrators often are former
academics themselves um so there's this
incredibly hierarchical environment
shall we say uh that that people and uh
and in those environments I think it
becomes much harder to go against the
grain yeah not to mention that there's
also just a growing number of
Administrators and positions and offices
period and often times now it's like
there's there's a whole new Dei
bureaucracy at on a campus and often
they're very young new hires that are
highly ideological as well so they might
not even be sensitive to professors in
this in the same way as somebody who
traditionally may have risen in the
ranks to a more prestigious
administrator spot and yet they wield a
ton of power over them which is really
frightening and I I mean I saw at NYU my
in my time there the amount of like
bureaucratic trip wires that were placed
around campus in terms of like even like
I I show up my first day I have to go
and pick up my ID from the public safety
office to get into all the buildings and
on the back it's like here's the phone
number for 911 if you have an emergency
here's the Student Health Center here's
our um like Mental Health hotline which
is actually sadly something that's I
think needed in college campuses today
and here's the bias response hotline I'm
like what the heck is that and I looked
into it and it turns out that quite
literally it's just like if you feel
that somebody crossed a line or
something was offensive that you can
call them which sounds as though I'm I'm
like somehow
downplaying perhaps there is I mean it's
a progressive University in lower
Manhattan but perhaps there are
instances of legitimate bias there are
administrators that you can certainly go
to and that's amply available and yet we
had a hotline and the school published
its own internal data and it was uh
something north of 2third of the
complaints Rose to the threshold of
somebody calling in and saying this is
an example that they gave of like the
category of someone coming in and saying
that there there were not diverse enough
um faces in the student or the the
advertisements of NYU of students that
they were photographing in the in the
advertisements and the school came out
and said this is what the majority of
these reports are so basically and they
were on the back of the bathroom stall
too we had Little posters the bias
response hotline and it was essentially
the school saying like you were so so
fragile and so able to be wounded by
words that we need to create a hotline
for you to call into and this is such an
actively apparently hostile environment
that you're going to be transgressed and
I mean I don't understand how how as a
freshman walking in not really knowing
what the kids in your classes are going
to be like orbe maybe having heterodox
ideas or coming from a different
background I mean it's literally just
saying like there's an institutionalized
way in which like your words can be used
against you where where you might get in
trouble or called in for something that
you say that might be an Artful and I I
mean it's just like a a very um creepy
sort of
dystopian world that these these
administrators sometimes create and
trying I think genuinely to to protect
kids and yet at the same time it creates
this environment where it just feels
like even the school itself is
weaponized against your your free speech
and and is hostile to it yeah and and
and I really that that's I mean I
mentioned the the the subtitle you know
of codling but our ours for this one is
cancel culture undermines trust and
threatens us all but there is a solution
but the undermining of trust in cancel
culture really can't be emphasized
enough and this is in informal ways like
I mentioned before the idea that one of
your friends you know can turn you in
you know for something that you snap
chatted is a very real you know fear um
you know we talk about a case where
someone you know lost their admission to
uh Kansas State University because
someone had been you know holding on to
a Snapchat uh video um that for for for
years and revealed it just you know just
at the time that she she was admitted to
school but that undermines interpersonal
trust which is horrifying um it's uh and
but it also you know it it it also
undermines um uh things like academic
freedom because when you ask professors
are they self-censoring the answer is I
mean and this is another way to compare
it to the to McCarthyism there was a
survey conducted of whether or not
professors were self-censoring um in
1954 I think um pretty large sample and
the number was about 9% of professors
said they were self-censoring due to the
Hostile political climate that's really
bad that's one out of 10 professors
saying that they are self-censoring
that's not good good for an academic
environment when we did this um and we
asked them you know are you
self-censoring in class are you
self-censoring online are you
self-censoring and and are and we were
clear our definition wasn't just like
not calling people fat kind of
self-censoring like you're withholding
your actual beliefs um and it was 90% um
of of professors you know say say that
they're self-censoring and when you have
institutions where it's like oh
everybody you know uh this is this is a
Marketplace of ideas but by the way
here's the number where you can secretly
call in your professor and make his life
hell or possibly get him fired um if he
says something that pisses you off and
looking at the polling I mean something
like 70 something percent of both
conservative and liberal students
thought that professors you know should
get in trouble or should be reported for
saying offensive things in class we've
we've uh we've got a long way to go that
90% number is shocking but not wholly
surprising um so you talk about these
institutions uh all right I think most
people would cop to the fact that hey
there's something going going on on
college campuses but it leaves college
campuses and then it heads to yes media
organizations it heads to nonprofits and
NOS uh it heads to corporations I'm
going to to uh look at media and
nonprofits because I think there it's
particularly strong I I was talking to
yasam monk who you probably know in our
friendly way um so uh and he and I um
commiserated about how we know these
nonprofit profits that have completely
been subsumed by internal turmoil
because the staffers come in and then
start agitating for better behavior in
on the part of the managers um as
opposed to doing whatever the
organization supposed to do and in many
cases these are left leaning
organizations uh and this was
particularly prevalent in 20 uh 21 U
2020 20 like this last several years
what which should have been a very very
busy time for a lot of these
organizations and a majority of these
leaders they actually said to me that
like there was a leader um who said that
their number one criteria when they're
interviewing new hires is is this person
going to try and get me fired in the the
next you know 12 months uh and and so
they're they're kind of uh living in
fear of their own staff yeah I I hear
that all the time from um from even
co-workers that are like at the we're we
apparently Waltz in US Jen ears is like
these like little tyrants that are also
very confusing and send like very
bizarre slack messages that apparently
are very cryptic I've been called out
for that as well but I you know there's
one example that I think is the most
compelling of a a business leader being
able to stand up to this very
effectively which was what coinbase did
which was effectively say like draw a
line in the sand and say we are not
going to be a political organization we
are not going to take up any partisan
positions one way or another as an
organization and if that's a problem for
you then step back and and you can you
can leave and I was surprised to hear
that 5% of them actually their employees
actually did and like that's a filtering
mechanism I mean that's a perfectly
reasonable stance to take as a business
leader who's not like running anything
even vaguely ideological besides like do
you have faith in blockchain I suppose
but like it's shocking to me that one in
20 people even still thought that it was
so offensive to them that that they
wouldn't be taking a stand on
contentious political issues that they
wanted to walk away but I'm quite sure
that those would be the 5% of people
that you probably didn't want to work
for you in the first place so I I find
that to be a remarkable story and
statistic but even Netflix recently I
think also um came out pretty solidly
and saying like we're going to publish
things that might make you uncomfortable
after the Dave Chappelle um controversy
and like if that's a problem for you
then this might not be the right place
for you and I think the what I've kind
of witnessed from afar is is this like
appeasement of these
these young people Waltzing in and and
wanting to tear everything down are just
being a little bit afraid of them and
saying oh we'll just let that like they
can just have this one thing or we'll
just put out this one statement that
we're not really totally sure about to
the point where it got so out of control
that it like we're we're at a moment
where it's like this it's it's our way
or the highway and I think that more
Business Leaders need to lean into that
attitude for sure yeah no it it's it's
one of these things that like after
coddling came out we wanted to have a
chapter on uh the trends we talk about
in coddling uh hitting the business
World cuz we knew it was happening we
just ran out of time to have it John was
constantly tweeting about kind of like I
really wish we could have gotten that in
it's was like yeah no it's fair but we
had to hand it in sometime um and after
codlin came out we heard from business
leader after business leader and I'm in
the nonprofit space and I've definitely
you know seen potential hires you know
who uh when you even in a free speech
organization that when you dig a little
bit deeper you're like oh but your
attitude is essentially that you you
will be the speech police in the
organization and what the way Fire's
been able to handle that weather that is
that we have a commitment to having
politically diverse staff it is
extremely important to us to have actual
liberals and conservatives working
together um and actually you know um the
staff does lean more to the left um but
at the same time having a healthy desire
to have people you disagree with to work
with is is something that's that's a um
commonly shared value that we all take
extremely seriously but I kept on also
hearing about how this was utterly
paralyzing cause-based nonprofits um I
had a friend who worked at after codling
came out she said I want to have a word
with you and I'm like oh boy um this is
actually my wife's friend um and I was
like I'm going to get rip the new one um
but it actually turned out she she was
the head of a nonprofit that did Direct
Services stuff like actually going out
and helping people you know in the real
world directly and it was completely
Paralyzed by the new hires who thought
everything had to be about the culture
at the office as opposed to helping the
people that they were helping and
meanwhile I'm not going to be like
someone who could every time I I was
told this by either a business uh a
profit or for-profit leader it'd always
be followed with but you can't tell
anybody about it and it was really
frustrating so that's what one the
reasons I'm eternally thankful to Ryan
Grim at The Intercept for writing an
article called The Elephant in the zoom
also a great title um where he talks
about how this is paralyzing you know
organizations like this this internal
kind of cancel culture that makes it you
know kind of a climate of fear and I
still think that is present um in a
particularly in a lot of the big
foundations I hear that a lot um and
it's
dysfunctional hey YouTube glad you're
enjoying the podcast if you really like
it hit subscribe and then YouTube will
notify you every time we have a bang up
new guest thank
you
I also feel like the more that I I've
become just like now at first on the
college campus I was the human
receptacle for everyone's Politically
Incorrect secrets and now it seems to be
like people from just spheres of life
that I've popped up on their radar and
they confide these things in me and I
feel like we're at a moment like it it
feels very akin to the the Harper's
letter um coming out and saying like we
don't all all of us at the same time are
going to say that we don't we this very
innocuous statement that we believe in
free speech and pluralism and and being
able to have conversations and not tear
people down and I feel like there's so
much secret momentum in in so many
people feeling the same way whether I
mean they they might not agree on
contentious issues but just agreeing on
the fact that that we've drifted so far
away from a free speech culture which is
what we advocate for in a book that like
I look at um and recently Harvard there
was a pre speech Alliance of professors
that came forward and there were a
hundred of them at the same time who
said we're establishing this
organization we think this is a problem
on campus and I I I mean I wrote about
it for the New York Post the article got
quite a lot of attention and yet none of
them really got personally attacked for
it because there's strength and numbers
and courage is contagious and they all
kind of did it at the same time rather
than the one person getting torn down
and then everyone else kind of cowering
away from actually you know giving them
any support so I feel like we are at a
cultural moment where there's the
numbers are huge of people who agree
with these very fundamental American
values and the the tyranny of the
minority I think is is a really
concerning Dynamic that I'm I'm watching
play out but like I it's I hear it all
the time from people in every single
kind of industry that like we're scared
of these very small very loud squeaky
Wheels in society and I'm I'm like
starting to feel like we need to just
all come down together and say like no
this is this is enough like we this
can't continue and that's something I'm
proud of with the book is we offer a lot
of solutions about a third of it is
talking about ways to improve parenting
K through 12 the uh how to keep your
corporation out of the culture War
reforms that you could do in higher ed
but one thing that we just like we
regretted not being able to fit um
something that we really were passionate
about into the book uh that's really
relevant to you Andrew is we think that
one of the ways one of the best ways to
really have a free each culture is to
work together to solve specific hard
problems not just a Consciousness raise
on the evil uh evils of the world but be
like how what do what's the brass tax on
how we do things like address police
abuses what or or on big Energy
Solutions um or on any of the or any of
the world's problems and I think that uh
we talk in the book we have a lot of uh
sections on the Ridiculousness of how
cancel culture is part of a
dysfunctional rhetorical tactic to win
arguments without actually winning
arguments um and we we we spend about
the the middle third of the book we go
through all the different ways that
we've learned to legitimize arguing
around the actual argument people are
making and making it all about ad homm
all about attacking the person and then
that will get you nowhere other than to
you know have a pic victory over
individuals or ruin a couple people's
lives but still not getting anywhere
closer to the truth but we have real
problems to solve and the best way to
Sol these problems is to have meaty
meaningful discussions that are focused
on the actual topic of the discussion so
solving problems is one of the ways that
you actually teach Free Speech culture
yeah I I thought it was his I thought it
was hysterical uh the barricades um
because it it seemed so familiar uh and
so I I and these were the kind of cheap
tactics that are used uh against folks
if you say something disagreeable so I'm
just going to go through some of the the
barricade so people have a sense of what
I'm talking about but I was like oh yeah
that does happen one is the speaker
conservative two what's the speaker's
race three what's the speaker's
gender four what's the speaker
sexuality you know and and we've all
kind of seen this it's like oh you can't
say anything cuz you know you're like a
straight white male um Can the speaker
be accused of being phobic are they
Guilty By Association did they lose
their cool did they violate a thought
terminating
cliche which also is funny but I mean
that is pretty much where we are Darkly
hint something else is really going
odd like there's um and I laugh because
they're all so familiar um they get used
all the time and it it was a joy to see
them just laid out and uh cataloged in
in this way um I loved how smartly you
went about it so the efficient
rhetorical Fortress is uh the way that
people on the right are able to dodge
arguments um and of course they also
have the mind field and the obstacle
course that they can fall back on but
they can also dismiss you if you're a
liberal um or on the left um and that
and that's the thing is you don't
actually have to for none of these do
you actually have to be on the left you
just have to be able to be accused of
that and that's practically anybody it's
also if you're a journalist if you're an
expert um and for the Maga wi that if
you disagree or dislike Trump like that
that that's a way to you know I think
it's funny that we get more hate mail
from prot Trump people about coddling
the American mind because apparently in
our discussion of of Charlottesville we
weren't you know sufficiently nice to
him but the perfect rhetorical
rhetorical Fortress is just like a
Wonder of construction it was something
uh you know designed in Academia so it's
just layer after layer largely of
identity-based uh Dodges but one thing I
I want to be really clear about is we
did the whole demographic analysis you
know to work out like how much of the
population do you eliminate when you
eliminate uh White conservatives when
you white people and conservatives when
you eliminate straight people white
conservatives what as you go down it
gets to a smaller and smaller group of
people that are you know that escape
that that uh that the dismissal and we
worked that out that by the end of it
you're up down to about 0.4% of the
population of the country uh but here's
here's the kicker um and that's the
phobic uh if you say the wrong thing
still doesn't matter like even if you're
right in that point 4% of of the most
intersectional person ever lived if you
say that if you have the wrong opinion
you are still dismissed you are accused
of internalized misogyny internalized
transphobia it um it's it's perfect uh
in the sense that it can dismiss anybody
and the one of the saddest but also sort
of Darkly funniest part of this is when
we talk to a lot of the black uh
conservative and black moderate authors
that we know um and ask them have you
ever been told you weren't really black
for an opinion that you had every single
one of them was like oh yeah oh yeah
that's that's kind of a common thing um
and John McWater talked about a reporter
after he said some dissenting things
saying oh so uh do you consider yourself
black and he was blown away by that and
Coleman Hughes put it really really well
he said I'm constantly being told that
the most important thing to as to my
credibility is the color of my skin um
but when I have a dissenting opinion
that they don't like I am told not
really black so it's perfect like that
there's no way like I'm damned if I do
damned if I don't and that's what it
reveals a lot of this to be essentially
a really complicated system for running
out the clock and prot protecting Dogma
not people um it's to it's to never
actually have to you know argue um about
the substance of what someone's talking
about so I I think we've done a pretty
good job of laying out why this is
important why it's uh destructive why
people should be concerned about it so
you are actually very constructive in
the last third of the book you talk
about the various ways that we can
address it as individuals the way that
institutions can address it uh so let's
talk about what people can do if they
are convinced they say okay guys I agree
cancel culture is a problem I too want
to stand up and say that a and provide
cover for other people who agree with me
that turns out it's most of us that are
not fans of this thing yeah we have a a
number of Reform chapters including how
higher education um should definitely
become a less kind of centralized and
and one route sort of world and that we
should be you know I I didn't finish my
degree and Greg changed his degree
requirements at fire in order to hire me
actually and I think Society needs to
wake up to the fact that we can't just
have a a single um very cancel culture
prone institution producing all the
leaders in in in every corporation and
every um government role and so I think
that that's one important solution that
we put forth um a lot of the stuff that
we talked about earlier on the
corporation front as well and what to me
is um the most interesting is our
conversation about K to2 education and
also parenting because I think a lot of
this gets to this is kind of my gen Z
bias coming out but a lot of this gets
to the fact that I I think that there's
a confusing and seemingly contradictory
phenomenon of young people right now
where it seems like we're the ones that
are doing this the most which is true
but it's not most of us and most of us
do I think it's something like 80% of
gen Z say that they have a negative view
of cancel culture higher than any other
generation most of us don't like this
and I you know it it bothered me for a
while I'm like why why can't we kind of
just overhaul this tyranny of the
minority why aren't more people coming
out and it's because like I my own
experience I just did not understand the
the fundamental principles of free
speech and Classical liberalism and how
profound that is and how delicate of a
balance that is until I did my leave of
absence from NYU and I actually started
reading on my own and I read John
Stewart Mill and I read the founding
documents and I was like whoa this is
like I've been taking this for granted
and so I think that there's a an impetus
on on restoring our K to2 education to
actually teach these principles of free
speech and pluralis and why our
inheritance is so profound and why it's
so delicate and why it's our civic duty
to uphold it and also for parents to
lead by example and to be very
deliberate in in raising a generation of
kids that can actually return to these
these nonpartisan fundamental American
values and so to me it's just it's just
a matter of activating the minority or
the majority of young people who would
like to see a change who would like to
live in a world where the dumb thing
that they say is as a teenager does not
ruin the rest of their lives and pretty
soon and we're going to have to have a
ceasefire on that front because
everybody that's starting a job today
had an iPhone when they were 10 so we've
all done and said really stupid things
so I think I think it's just a matter of
actually like like allowing the the fire
of like free speech and and pluralism
and democracy to burn Again by just
actually telling young people like yes
you're right that something's wrong and
here's where we've gone ay and here is
how the founding fathers and here is how
American American legal Doctrine
actually has a path forward for us to to
get back on
track this podcast is sponsored by Helix
sleep it's a pretty short list of things
you can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now I call it a culture of Grace and
tolerance and what Ricky just said about
the 10-year-olds with the iPhones really
puts a point on it I mean who among has
not uh said something uh
regrettable uh in private to our friends
uh via text I mean that's everybody when
I see someone get slammed for that I'm
like that is seriously messed up um and
then even as someone who uh you know is
is on social media uh and has a you know
microphone in my face or a camera in my
face all the time it's like you know
it's like you know what are the odds of
someone saying something um you know off
color subject to interpretation even
mistaken or wrong over time it's like
100% you know what I mean so so yeah uh
so we we can't make it so that folks uh
feel like they're taking their career
into their hands anytime they make any
kind of statement then you wind up with
this like very very strange culture of
Conformity and cowardice and that's
going to end up serving us up to
something very very dark um which by the
way I now see that that's probably the
most likely path I mean that that's Ian
know like I'm I'm like you Greg I'm like
temperamentally optimistic even if I
think things are uh getting increasingly
demented um but I have a theory as to
how we can break the fever and it's by
on and it's by everyone buying this book
it's by everyone following Ricky and you
and Jonathan height and John mcer and
Coleman Hughes because so much of this
in my
opinion is folks seeking positive
affirmation and social reinforcement and
you you you get points for slamming
people you get points for saying like
Hey we're better than them uh look look
out how venal and corrupt they are um
but if that stuff doesn't get you clicks
and likes and everyone just rolls their
eyes and it's like whatever and uh
really
actual uh thinking and discussion is
where all of the attention goes
uh I I think that's the answer um and I
think your book's a big part of the
answer because you lay out an
intellectual case in a way that I have
not seen anywhere else thank you Andrew
you that means the world please do get a
copy of this brand new book The
cancelling of the American Mind by Greg
lukanov and Ricky schlot cancel culture
undermines trust destroys institutions
and threatens us all it actually does
but there is a solution and the solution
is to uncan your own mind and uh tell
your friends hey it's okay to say and
think certain things and we should all
be able to accept each other based upon
our shared Humanity perhaps our
americanness perhaps our uh fallibility
U but there are are ancient values in
that direction and this fever will break
it is a moment in time um I can't
believe that it's bigger than the Red
Scare just CU I remember reading about
the Red Scare in uh my history textbooks
and I look forward to a time when people
can read about this in their history
textbooks as like remember that crazy
period you American life when all these
people were getting cancelled thank
goodness we put that behind us yeah well
the big difference between this and the
Red Scare was that there was reason to
be really freaked out in the early 50s
American and British spies actually
helped you know um super Hitler Stalin
someone who actually killed more people
than than even Hitler get the bomb and
and what one of the reasons why cancel
culture is so weird as a mass censorship
event is that usually Mass censorship
events happen when there's a national
security crisis of the highest measure
like right before a war or when people
are paranoid about you know like the the
idea of of if I was around when I
suddenly discovered that Stalin got the
hydrogen bomb I'd be pretty freaked out
meanwhile we don't you didn't have a
comparable thing going on in cancel
culture so it makes it all and and and
back then the law wasn't even clear yet
whereas now the law is very protective
of freedom of speech and it's still
happening so I think I think we're going
to be looking back at this with wow when
people first got on social media and
mass numbers it drove everybody insane
hopefully there will be a return to
sanity if there is you two will be a big
part of it how can people follow you and
keep up with your work aside from buying
this
book uh the fire.org um I also have a
substat called the eternally radical
idea but the fire the you know check out
the fire.org
and I'm on Twitter and my New York Post
column is uh popping up in the paper
here and there so keep an eye out for it
Ricky schlot is going to outdo all of us
thank you both so much and and
congratulations on on this uh this book
it's a real achievement thank you thank
[Music]
you